-Welcome back to the show.
Yeah, they love you, buddy.
-Whew!
-We go back a long ways.
Do you remember
the first time we hung out?
-The Derby.
-The Kentucky Derby.
-I was onstage.
I was dating my now-wife.
And I was dating her.
And I jumped on the stage
and I was singing with the band
or something like that.
-You sing? No.
-Yeah, twist my arm.
Yeah, I was doing --
It was yelling, really.
And I got off the stage.
I go, "Where's Nancy?"
And they go, "Oh,
your girlfriend is so cool, man.
She's over there hanging
with the Manning brothers."
And she was
chugging a bottle of vodka.
-Yeah. That's what we do.
-I go, "Honey,
you don't do that."
She's like,
"Those guys are just so fun."
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
-I didn't see her
the next day at the Derby.
-She didn't make it
to the Derby. No, no.
We didn't -- No.
Right now, you're the number-1
trending video
on the Internet, by the way.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is really funny.
You did this
with Omaha Productions.
You wore a disguise
and tried out as a walk-on
for the
Penn State football team.
-Yes. Yes. Chad Powers.
-Chad Powers.
Can I just show everyone?
This is Chad Powers.
-Ooh, yes.
That's a good-looking man
right there.
-Dude, I want to show
everyone a clip,
'cause it's really good.
Take a look at this.
-Hey. I'm Chad Powers.
Think fast, run fast.
Look up "arm" in the dictionary,
you see a picture of Chad.
Chad Powers.
You ain't seen nothing like him.
-Is he good?
-Chad Powers, you're ineligible.
-I thought I had it, boys.
But, you know, I'm sorry.
But, you know...
I'm just a 41-year-old who just
wants to play ball, man.
I'm just trying to get back out
there, play some ball.
-Yeah, I mean, come on.
That was so fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
First of all, how --
how did Chad Powers --
How did you pull this off?
Who knew?
-Well, I mean, I think just
a great flow, a mustache,
and a great name,
a lot of good things happen.
-How did you come up
with Chad Powers?
-Well, he's got two --
really three great uncles.
He's got Austin Powers.
-What a great backstory.
-He's got Kenny Powers.
And then Uncle Rico.
So, I mean,
there's a combination there.
-But did people freak out
and were like,
"Hey, I'm actually
threatened by Chad Powers."
-Oh, yeah, no,
I was slingin' it.
-Yeah, of course you were.
-Chad can throw it.
Chad can really throw it.
He's a good player.
He would have made the team,
but he's ineligible.
-But I was
talking to you backstage.
I go,
"That was cool you do that."
And I go, "Have you ever been
recognized for
a different celebrity?"
And you said, "A lot"?
It comes up all the time.
-It comes up all the time.
Just, you know,
not too long ago, this summer,
I'm taking the girls fishing,
and we're kind of driving.
And I pull over to get some
water, get some snacks,
go into a store.
And, you know,
I get to the counter,
and the guy
looks at me and goes,
"Are you who I think you are?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I think so."
He goes, "Oh, my gosh!
Michael Phelps is any store!"
He's like, "Everybody, come out!
It's Michael Phelps!"
I'm like, "Whoa. No, no, no.
No, no, no.
I'm not Michael Phelps."
He's like, "So you lied to me?"
I'm like, "No.
I just thought
who you thought I was
is not who I am
and you thought I was not
who I think I thought
you were or whatever.
-Now, I can kind of see it.
-Something like that.
-Yeah, you can kind of do it.
-That looks like Blue Steel.
-Yeah, he's gonna do a
Blue Steel.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about your show,
but I also want to
talk about football.
Of course, the big story
everyone's talking about
is Tom Brady.
He's back. He retired.
Then he didn't retire.
Did you know that he was --
-I had a feeling.
I saw him not too long
after he retired.
And -- "Hey, congratulations."
He was like,
"Well, you never know.
Like, I'm still working out
a little bit."
I'm like, "Oh, yeah,
he's coming back."
100%."
-Yeah. But when you retired,
you said --
-I knew. I was like,
"I am not doing anything.
I'm taking a month,
I'm taking two months off.
I'm not going to train.
Like, I just --
I want to relax."
And, you know, when I saw,
he was like, "Yeah..."
I mean, I knew 1,000%
I was not playing football.
If there's like
a 10% chance or a 2% chance,
then you're coming back.
-Yeah. I know
you're friendly with him,
but do you ever remind Tom
that you're the only quarterback
in NFL history to beat him
twice in a Super Bowl?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I do not, I do not.
-I'm just saying,
it's just something --
something that might come up.
-I see Tom, and we're friendly.
And I never bring it up to him
because, I mean, the guy's got
seven Super Bowl rings.
He's MVP.
I have no bragging rights
anywhere near him.
But he --
-He's got three more fingers.
-He will bring up the 2007 game,
when they were undefeated.
They would have gone down as
the greatest team of all time
and go undefeated,
and he can't say that now.
And he blames me.
And I'm okay with that.
I can accept that.
I took one for the team,
you know?
-Yeah, you really did.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Yeah, well, every now and then,
if you want to bring it up
to him, it's always
good to -- humbling --
just humble him a little bit.
You're very, very busy.
You've got
the ManningCast on ESPN
with your brother, who's --
Gosh, he's so funny, as well.
You guys together are just --
-He's funny-looking.
Funny-looking.
-Oh, he's funny-looking.
Yeah, yeah.
But you're also
the co-owner of Gotham FC.
-Yes.
-This is a professional
women's soccer team.
-Yes. It's right here
in New Jersey.
It's the
New York/New Jersey team.
And it's right in our backyard,
where we live.
They practice
15, 20 minutes away.
They play at Red Bull Arena
in New Jersey.
And really got involved because
when I grew up,
my dad played
professional football.
He retired when
I was 3 years old.
But we'd still
go to Saints practices
and we'd go to games.
And I got to go in
the locker room and meet
these players
who were my heroes.
And I really wanted the
same experience for my kids.
I have four kids,
but I have three girls,
and they're all athletes.
And for them to see these
professional athletes
and go to practice and meet them
and go to the games
and say, "Hey, you know --"
I want them to have
role models and to show them
that it's cool to play sports,
and if you work hard, you can be
a professional athlete.
You don't have to,
but, like, you know,
just to have someone
to look up to
and, you know,
give these girls an opportunity.
I love that they're playing
professional sports.
And just think, you know,
sports are so great for
everybody to get involved in.
-Good for you.
I like that you're doing that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I have two girls, too.
They'd love that.
So, "The Eli Manning Show."
-Yes.
-It's back for a second season.
Groundbreaking show.
-Yes.
-Tell me what happens.
Describe what happens
on the show.
-Okay.
So, it's really a new concept.
I don't think
it's ever been done before.
I'm a host and I have a show.
and I invite guests on,
and they come
and they sit in a chair.
And I'll ask them questions.
Sometimes, they're promoting
something -- a show, a movie.
Sometimes,
we do skits and, like,
different games or sing songs.
-Wow. Wow.
-Have you ever
heard of anything --
-No, I've never heard of
anything like that in my life.
"The Eli Manning Show."
-It's original.
-Yeah. The title is good.
-We get a lot of Giants fans.
A lot of Giants fans.
-Exactly.
-It's got a new title.
-Is it hard for you?
It is interesting
and it's a different thing
to be a talk show host
from being a quarterback.
I mean, obviously.
-Yeah, it is hard.
I think it's a natural --
It's a natural just,
you know, progression.
-Yeah, a normal, natural thing.
-Yeah.
-You're very good at it.
-Season 1, you had
some giant names on there.
-Yeah.
-And it's Season 2.
Who do you got
coming up for this season?
-Well, we had Ryan Reynolds.
-You had Bill Murray.
-Yeah, we had
Bill Murray last year.
We have you. You're coming on.
-That's right.
-Yeah!
-I'm very excited about that.
-Yes.
-I'm very excited.
We're going to
play some cornhole.
-Cornhole, let's go.
-Let's go for it, bud.
You're going to go down.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at
"The Eli Manning Show."
Take a look at this.
-Can we get
two regular hot dogs?
-Two regular hot dogs coming up.
Some onions.
Just some regular onions.
Look at this.
Boom, boom, boom.
Wait. I have a question.
Have you heard that
"The Eli Manning Show"
is coming back for Season 2?
-The what?
-"The Eli Manning Show."
You haven't seen
"The Eli Manning Show?"
-What is it on?
-I don't -- Don't ask me the
hard questions like that.
You know? It's on YouTube.
-We'll look it up.
-I got pretzels and hot dogs.
Pretzels and hot dogs.
How you doing, sir? Hot dog?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash, sad tuba plays ]
-He still wins!
-That hurt.
-That hurt you right there.
Eli Manning, everybody.
Check out
"The Eli Manning Show,"
streaming now on
the Giants' YouTube channel.
We'll be right back with
Chef José Andrés.
Stick around.